3 le ruban est coupé la maison de la
famille et la casoar réouvrent à censir
l'école oui oui c'est pratique puisque
tout est au même endroit donc ça évite
d'aller à droite à gauche pour quelqu'un
qui habite la ville ça peut
effectivement être en plus pour les
démarches surtout
les on a des nous les personnes âgées on
a des démarches des fois à faire c'est
bien utile après près de 2 ans de
travaux et 2,4 million d'euros investis
les locaux sont neufs et
réaménagé la maison de la famille
regroupe les services dédiés à la
famille planning familial service
logement CCAS et
périscolaire le nouveau bâtiment permet
un accès plus simple à des aides comme
Eveline médiation des assistantes
sociales et la Croix Rouge pour
l'alphabétisation un seul guichet un
seul endroit vous avez par exemple une
personne en difficulté qui vient faire
une demande par exemple de logement mais
elle a aussi peut-être un problème avec
une donc on peut en frappant à la porte
d'un côté elle a tout de suite une
assistante sociale plutôt que de dire
aux gens il faudrait que vous preniez
rendez-vous voilà on va vous donner
l'adresse là tout peut être fait dans
une seule visite la casoir quant à elle
est situé dans les sous-sols du bâtiment
de la maison de la famille c'est un
espace dédié à la culture avec des
locaux entièrement réaménagés la case
auart dispose d'une salle de spectacle
d'un studio d'enregistrement et d'une
salle de répétition les locaux sont
accessibles à tous sur simple
inscription